Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit. Die 39. Ausgabe wieder einmal mit Tim Pritlove. Das hier ist die Gesprächsreihe von ESA und DLR. Und auch hier wollen wir heute wieder tief in ein Thema einsteigen, das Einblicke gibt in die Raumfahrt. Und jetzt steht ohnehin mal eine Serie von Gesprächen an, die wir im Prinzip so auch schon begonnen haben, nämlich ein engerer Blick auf unser Sonnensystem. Da haben wir dann mit den Sendungen zu Cassini-Huygens und dem Saturn-System im Prinzip auch schon mal begonnen. Heute allerdings wollen wir den Blick in unsere unmittelbare Nachbarschaft werfen, und zwar auf den Erdmond. Und um da umfangreiche Informationen zu bekommen, begrüße ich Harald Hoffmann. Willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist auch einer aus dem Team, was hier schon häufiger zu hören war, vom Institut für Planetenforschung beim DLR in Berlin. Sollen wir nochmal eine spezielle Unterabteilung, der du da irgendwie zugeordnet bist?
Ja, ich bin in der Abteilung für Planetengeologie.
Genau.
Und damit wird auch gleich deutlich, vom Beruf her bin ich eben Geologe und befasse mich mit den vorwiegenden terrestrischen Körpern.
Und dem Mond im Besonderen. Auch. Auch.
Ansonsten, auch Mass natürlich, da wir laufende Missionen haben, vergleicht man eben auch die unterschiedlichen Körper miteinander.
Ja. Trotzdem ist ja der Mond irgendwie so ein bisschen auch schon immer so das romantische Ziel gewesen, so das einzige Objekt, was ohne größere Apparatur immer schon früher schon im Detail erkennbar war. Also wenn man sich bemüht, dann kann man eben Katerstrukturen etc. alles schon ausmachen. Die Erklärung dafür war natürlich über die Zeit sehr vielfältig. Trotz alledem hat der Mond schon immer alle bewegt. Religion, Kultur, Geschichte etc. Ganz klar. Und natürlich auch für die Raumfahrt war es eigentlich so ein bisschen der Kickoff. Habe ich immer wieder so den Eindruck, dass so der Flug zum Mond so eigentlich immer so der Traum schlechthin war, also bevor die Ziele dann weiter gesteckt wurden zumindest.
Das hat ja schon Gilles Verne in seiner Bücher gefasst und niedergeschrieben. Und es war sicherlich, also ich kann mich noch erinnern, 69 bei der Landung, da als kleiner Stepp gesaß ich dann vor dem Fernseher, durfte lange aufbleiben und zuschauen. Und das hat natürlich dann den späteren Lebensweg geprägt. Solche Ereignisse.
Warst du auch Science-Fiction gelesen?
Natürlich. Tut man ja heutzutage auch noch.
Ja, das tut man auch noch, das war nicht ganz aus der Mode gekommen. Ja, und du hast dich dann für ein Studium der Geologie entschieden?
Ja, aber da habe ich noch nicht an Planeten gedacht, das kam dann erst später, oder weniger durch Zufall.
Schon gar nicht an Raumfahrt?
Gar nicht an Raumfahrt anfangs. Sondern? Zuerst mehr Ölbranche und dann kam halt hier irgendwie das DLR damals noch in München in die Quere. Da hatte ich die Möglichkeit anzufangen, Ende der 80er und dann bin ich dabei geblieben.
Das heißt, bist dann in Oberpfaffenhofen dann dazugestoßen?
Genau, da hatte ich angefangen und dann später nach Berlin im Rahmen der Vereinigung kam ja dann hier die Verlagerung sämtlicher Planetenforschungsaktivitäten nach Berlin. Und ja, seitdem bin ich dann praktisch in Berlin gelandet. Und es ging ja auch gleich richtig los damals.
Welches damals war das dann?
Ja, eben Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er gab es eben die Galileo-Mission zum Jupiter-System und die hat ja, um genügend Schwung aufzunehmen, ist die um das Erdemond-System herumgeflogen, also ein Swing-By-Vorbeiflug gemacht, Energie aufgenommen, Geschwindigkeit aufgenommen und dabei kam sie eben am Mond vorbei und hat dann nach langer, langer Zeit erstmals wieder wissenschaftliche Daten, insbesondere auch Bilddaten mit modernen Instrumenten von der Mondoberfläche geliefert, die ihr seit dem Ende von Apollo und den Lunamissionen eigentlich verweist war. Da ist ja nichts passiert, was sich irgendwie mit dem Mond beschäftigt hatte über lange Jahre und das waren dann so mal wieder die ersten Blicke auf den Mond, die man hatte und mit denen man auch erstmals zum Beispiel das größte Becken im Sonnensystem wirklich nachweisen konnte. Das ist auf Proletten gewesen. Aber da kommen wir später dazu vermutlich nochmal.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, ja das ist ja überhaupt sehr interessant. Also am Anfang war es so ein bisschen der Inbegriff der Sehnsucht, dann der Ansturm, das ja ein Wettlauf im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zwischen den Nationen auch, um dort möglichst nah an den Mond heranzukommen, darauf zu landen und später dann auf einmal großes Desinteresse. Auf einmal war dann so der Rest des Universums spannender.
Richtig, also nach 1973 ist eigentlich nicht mehr viel am Mond passiert. Noch die eine oder andere sowjetische Mission, aber das war es dann eben bis 1991.
Was war denn jetzt am Anfang, war denn das wissenschaftliche Interesse am Anfang eigentlich beim Mond wirklich das Bestimmte? Man hatte eigentlich mehr so den Eindruck, es ging eigentlich erstmal mehr um das Hinkommen, Dasein, Dagewesensein, Party gefeiert haben.
Also Party gefeiert haben vermutlich weniger, aber zumindest hinkommen, dort landen, demonstrieren, dass man stärker ist, wie die andere Welt macht. Das war ja sicherlich dem Kalten Krieg geschuldet, dass hier so viele Gelder und so viel Mittel und Energie hineingeflossen sind und man bereit war, das eben auch alles aufzubringen, um möglichst schnell und als Erster auf dem Mond landen zu können. Und da waren ja eben Sowjetunion und Amerika hier direkt im Wettstreit. Der erste Satellit Sputnik und dann kam der große Aufschrei vom Westen und man hat versucht, auf dem Mond zu landen. Das heißt, die Missionen waren sicherlich nicht von der Wissenschaft getriggert, sondern sie waren eindeutig politisch gewollt und eine Demonstration, aber sie haben eben als Abfallprodukt quasi auch sehr viel Wissenschaft geliefert.
Und was hat der Mensch dann in dieser ersten Phase über den Mond gelernt? Was wissen wir jetzt? Was ist denn dieser Mond eigentlich?
Ich meine, das beste Beispiel, als ich noch angefangen habe, zu studieren, da war immer noch nicht ganz klar, ist alles hier auf dem Mond. Gibt es wirklich Krater? Sind Krater so wichtig? Und vom Mond wissen wir eben, dass Impact-Prozesse hier im Sonnensystem eine große Rolle spielen, eben auch für die Erde. Erst danach konnten wir nachweisen, dass auch hier auf der Erde viele Impact-Becken, Einschlagsbecken existieren, wie es in Nordlingaris, hier in Deutschland oder Steinheimer Becken, große Einschlagsbecken. Und es ist gelungen, Proben vom Mond zurückzubringen, die man immer laboratdetailliert untersuchen konnte und eben die genetische Verwandtschaft zwischen Erde und Mond feststellen konnte.
Woran hat man die festgestellt?
Das basiert im Endeffekt auf dem Chemismus, dass eben doch sehr, sehr große Ähnlichkeit zwischen Mantelmaterial und dem Gesamtmond besteht. Und in der, ja also wie genau der Mond entstanden ist, gab es, oder gibt es eigentlich auch heute noch unterschiedliche Theorien. Momentan die Präferierte ist eben die, dass in der Frühphase der Erde ein sehr großes Objekt, etwa Maßgröße, mit der Erde kollidiert ist. Und dabei sehr viel Mantelmaterial ausgeworfen wurde. Und aus diesem Mantelmaterial quasi dann sich der Mond geblendet hat.
Also mit Mantelmaterial meinen wir Erdmantel. Erdmantel, die Oberfläche der Erde.
Nein, nicht die Astrosphäre, also mehr, deutlich mehr. Nicht die Kruste. Die Oberfläche ist ja die Kruste. Der Erdmantel ist die dynamische, der obere Mantel.
Wie dick ist das dann so, wenn man vom Mantel spricht? Viel.
Viel, mehrere tausend.
Also immerhin kam ja ein ganzer Mond bei raus. Aber ich meine, dieses Objekt muss ja dann auch irgendwie Teil der Mischung sein.
Ist sicherlich Teil der Mischung. Viel ist verdampft, ist vieles mitkondensiert, hat sich vermischt. Natürlich. Also aber wie gesagt, das ist eine Theorie. Es gibt andere Überlegungen, in denen davon ausgegangen wird, möglicherweise Co-Aggression. Was heißt das? Also das heißt, aus der Planetenscheibe, aus der die Erde entstanden ist, hat sich eben auch der Mond peripher mitgebildet. Es sind beide zusammen aggressioniert, haben sich zusammengeballt.
Und das ist immer noch unklar.
Sagen wir mal so, es gibt immer noch Wissenschaftler, die die eine oder die andere Theorie vertreten, wobei die Mehrzahl sicherlich zu dem großen Impact neigt.
Aber so richtig bewiesen ist da noch gar nix.
Es sprechen viele Fakten sicherlich für einen großen Impact. Man kann vieles damit erklären. Es gibt Argumente, die dagegen sprechen, die auch wiederum aus Esotopenzusammensetzung oder sonstigen anderen Details resultieren. Also ich halte das Thema noch nicht für abgeschlossen.
Das heißt, es gibt auch durchaus noch eine Menge Forschungsbedarf und vor allem auch noch Klärungsbedarf auf dem Mond?
Richtig und vor allem, nachdem man jetzt in neuester Zeit ist ja aufgekommen, dass man doch wasserhaltige Minerale in Mondmaterial entdeckt hat. Also dank neuer Analysemethoden, mit denen man wieder zum Beispiel an vulkanische Gläser herangegangen ist und Einschlüsse dort untersucht hat, konnte man feststellen, dass in geringen Mengen denn doch Wasser auf dem Mond vorhanden ist. Im ursprünglichen, also vermutlich im ursprünglichen Magma, in der ursprünglichen Zusammensetzung, was man früher eben nicht angenommen hat. Also die ersten Analysen, die man von den Mondproben gemacht hat, bis anfang dieses Jahrtausends, ging man davon aus, der Mond ist eigentlich trocken. Völlig trocken, hat also keine volatilen Bestandteile im Magma besessen, also volatil in dem Fall wie Wasserstoff.
Was verdampft und dann einfach entweicht weg ist.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Oder eben in nur ganz geringen Maßen und das war eben doch ein großer Unterschied auch gegenüber der Erde. Und jetzt hat man festgestellt, oha, da ist doch wirklich in vulkanisch entstandene Material, befindet sich vermutlich lunares Wasser. Das ist eine ziemliche Überraschung, die man erstmal erklären muss. Also das ist jetzt ja wenige Jahre her, dass das entdeckt wurde.
Also, obwohl man den Mond schon so lange nachstellt, weiß man eigentlich noch relativ wenig, kann man zusammenfassen.
Es gab in den 90er Jahren, gab es einen berühmten Spruch, was soll ich denn auf dem Mond? Das ist ein toter Felsblock. Wir kennen alles, wir waren schon mal dort. Da muss man nicht mehr hin. Und jetzt gerade die neueren Missionen dieses Jahrtausends oder auch in den 90er Jahren haben eben gezeigt, dass der Mond doch viel spannender ist und wir haben viele neue Erkenntnisse gewonnen und viele offene Fragen, die dadurch neu entstanden sind und für die es eben spannend ist, weiter zu forschen.
Spulen wir noch mal ein bisschen zurück hier in die Geschichte des 20. Jahrhunderts. Als man sich also erstmals aufmachte zum Mond, bis dahin war die Auseinandersetzung mit dem Mond allein auf Beobachtung basiert. Daraus ließ sich ja sicherlich schon einiges ableiten. Man hatte eine Vorstellung von Massen und Kräften, so dass man dann letzten Endes eben auch einen Flug dorthin planen konnte. Was war denn, also ich meine, gut ausschlaggebend war wahrscheinlich dieser von uns angesprochene Wettlauf, dieser Sprung ins Weltall, so ein bisschen ausgelöst durch Sputnik. So, oh Gott, das funktioniert ja wirklich, dass man da oben Sachen fliegen lassen kann. Wenn wir schon so weit sind, dann können wir auch gleich zum Mond. Dann wurde ja dann in der Folge verschiedene Missionen gestartet. Wonach sah es denn am Anfang eigentlich aus? Wer hatte denn da zunächst die Nase vorn? Waren es immer schon die Amerikaner?
Nein, also am Anfang waren sicherlich die Sowjetunion, die das erste Mal Bilder von der Mondrückseite zur Erde gefunkt haben. Das kam erst gegen Ende dann mit der bemannten Mission, also mit Apollo, dass eigentlich die Amerika dann die Nase vorn hatte. Wobei Amerika hat sehr viele Missionen im Vorfeld gestartet zur detaillierten Erkundung, die also unerreicht sind mit den Daten, Luna Orbiter. Eine ganze Serie mit Kameras, die sind noch nach einem alten Fax-Prinzip zur Erde geschickt worden, die Daten. Deswegen sind da immer so die Streifen drin. Manche haben die vielleicht schon gesehen, diese Daten, die von manchen Stellen noch immer die beste Auflösung geliefert haben. Es gab dann die ersten einschlagenden Missionen, die also ungebremst quasi auf die Mondoberfläche geknallt sind, Ranger und dann später gab es noch die Surveyor, die weich gelandet sind und wirklich die ersten Messungen auch vor Ort gemacht haben und chemische Analysen, zum Beispiel vom Tycho am Tycho-Krater zur Erde gefunkt hatten, bis dann schließlich mit Apollo, der Mensch zum Mond vorgestoßen ist.
Das heißt, ich glaube, die Ranger-Sachen waren sogar noch vorher, das war...
Sie waren noch vor Surveyor.
Genau. Also Anfang der 60er Jahre, 61 ging es damit los. Das heißt, man wollte überhaupt erst mal rausfinden, was ist da eigentlich?
Na zuerst mal musste man die Technik schaffen, man musste den Mond erreichen.
Überhaupt erst mal hinkommen?
Erst mal hinkommen, erst mal ihn treffen. Das sind ja viele Missionen, sind ja unterwegs, weiß der Teufel, wohin geflogen, aber eben nicht zum Mond. Dass man wirklich den Mond trifft und ja, erst mal treffen, vielleicht auch in Orbit einschließen, eben die ersten Orbiter.
Das war dann sozusagen erst mal die Herausforderung.
Genau. Und also vorwiegend technisch getriggert und die Vorbereitung eben, die Erkundung, damit man weiß, wo will ich denn landen, was will ich machen. Wie gesagt, bis dann eigentlich die Proben zur Erde zurück kamen, war immer noch der Streit, was sind denn wirklich diese ganzen Krater. Vermutlich sind es Einschlagskrater, viele davon könnten aber auch vulkanischen Ursprung sein. Wie ist die Oberfläche beschaffen? Man hat ja Angst gehabt, dass die Mondsonden einsinken können auf der Mondoberfläche und da auch viele Vorkehrungen getroffen, dass da nichts passieren kann, bis man dann feststellte, naja, der ist doch vergleichsweise tragfähig.
Dieser Lunar Orbiter hat ja im Prinzip das erste Bild vom Mond geliefert, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Na das waren eigentlich...
Also richtig von der Mondoberfläche, meine ich. Also aus nächster Nähe.
Das war ein Lunar Orbiter aus nächster Nähe mit hoher Auflösung. Richtig. Und die ersten Aufnahmen aber von der Mondrückseite, das war eine Sond-Mission, eine sowjetische Mission. War damals sicherlich auch spannend, da hat dann der englische Geheimdienst es geschafft, diese Daten abzufangen und noch schneller zu veröffentlichen wie die Sowjetunion. Also das war ein ziemliches hin und her zwischen den beiden Mächten.
Dann kam es zur Apollo-Serie, die halt zum Ziel hatte, Menschen direkt auf den Mond zu bringen. Das ist ja eine, ich glaube bis heute, wenn man das mal vergleicht mit den Etats von Staaten, was da an Geld reingeschmissen wurde, eine unwiderholte Leistung einer Nation, die dann auch im Bau einer Rakete gipfelt, die es ja in der Leistungsfähigkeit auch heute noch nicht wiedergibt. Es gab ja mehrere Apollo-Missionen. Man redet immer natürlich von der ersten wirklichen Erfolgreichen, die dann halt den ersten Menschen so zum Mond gebracht hat. Aber wie hat sich da die Dynamik eigentlich entwickelt? Wie hat man sich dem Mond genähert?
Ich meine, mit der bebandenen Raubfahrt hat man ja angefangen mit Mercury und Gemini-Programm. Da gab es ja auch viele oder mehrere Unfälle. Auch Apollo 1 ist ja eigentlich ein Unfall gewesen. Da ist man an der Stadtrampe quasi verbrannt. Und man hat dann versucht, erst in den Earth Orbit richtig zu kommen, den Mond zu erreichen, um den Mond herum zu fliegen, wieder zur Erde zurück und dann im Earth Orbit einzufliegen, mit Apollo 10. Die Tests mit der Landefähre zu machen, das war ein schwieriges Ankoppelungsmanöver zwischen Landefähre und der Apollo-Kapsel. Das hat man vorher erst probieren müssen. Und dann mit Apollo 11, eben 69, ist ja die erste Landung geschafft worden.
War das überraschend eigentlich?
Ja, das war ziemlich riskant und die haben ja quasi mit dem letzten Tropfen Treibstoff.
Haben sie es gerade so eben geschafft?
Haben sie es noch so geschafft. Die Geschichte kennt man ja vermutlich mit viel Glück und dank eines guten Kommandanten mit gutem Auge konnte man Hindernissen ausweichen und noch glücklich landen. Ja und dann wurden weitere Landungen durchgeführt bis zur Apollo 17. Das war die letzte. Hat erstmals einen Wissenschaftler, also einen Geologen, auf die Oberfläche gebracht und da merkt man auch sofort, die Proben dieser Mission sind eigentlich die die besten aus dem gesamten Apollo-Programm.
Wer war denn vorher oben?
Na vorher waren es vorwiegend Piloten, die natürlich trainiert wurden und die eine hervorragende Arbeit geleistet haben, aber noch nicht das geschulte Auge hatten.
Die nicht in dem Maße die wissenschaftliche Basis haben. Heutzutage sind Astronauten vollwertige Wissenschaftler. Nicht nur das, auch extrem vielseitige Wissenschaftler in der Regel. Das gilt überhaupt für viele Wissenschaftler. Raumfahrtbereich, wenn man sich das hier auch bei Raumzeit immer wieder abzeichnet, gibt es natürlich immer Spezialisten für bestimmte Bereiche, aber eine sehr breite Ausbildung macht sich doch meistens da deutlich und bei den Astronauten hat es noch mal eine besondere Bedeutung. Und seitdem ist es dann wahrscheinlich auch so. Das heißt, dann hatte man das erste Mal ein Mondgestein, man hatte Kontakt gehabt mit dem Mond. Welches Bild des Mondes hat sich denn dann sozusagen präsentiert? Was weiß man? Woraus besteht der Mond?
Also der Mond in seiner Zusammensetzung ist, ich hatte es vorhin schon erwähnt, ähnlich wie der Erdmantel. Das ist also ein mafisches Material. Wir haben sehr viel Feldspat. Wir haben die Minerale Pyroxen, also Oto-Pyroxen, Clino-Pyroxen. Es sind Olivene vorhanden. Es ist Ilmenit vorhanden. Das sind so die wesentlichen Bauteile.
Was sind das für Stoffe?
Das sind, mit Ausnahme von Ilmenit, was ein Eisen-Titanoxid ist, sind die anderen sind alles Silicate. Also es ist eben ein silikatischer Körper mit einer eher Basalt-ähnlichen Zusammensetzung. Allein schon von der Erde sieht man ja auf der Vorderseite diese dunklen Bereiche und die hellen Bereiche und das kann man auch klar zuordnen. Die hellen Bereiche sind Hochland, sind felspart reiches Material, was relativ früh entstanden ist und die dunklen Bereiche sind eben vulkanisches Material, basaltisches Material, was dann etwas später ausgeflossen ist. Da kann man inzwischen dann auch deutliche Alterszuordnungen machen. Diese dunklen Flecken, die man von der Erde aussieht, das sind eben große Einschlagsbecken, die gefüllt wurden dann später, etwa vor der 3,9 bis sogar bis bis 1,5 Milliarden Jahren mit vulkanischen Basalten. Und das sind eben diese dunklen Flecken, wohingegen diese hellen Bereiche vorwiegend feldspatreich sind und von denen man annimmt, dass sie Reste eigentlich eines Magmaozeans sind. Also sprich in der Frühphase, kurz nach der Bildung, ist die gesamte äußere Kruste aufgeschmolzen. Es entstand ein Magmaozean und dort sind dann Feldspäte auskristallisiert und haben die erste Kruste gebildet.
Das heißt, eigentlich hat der Mond jetzt mal abgesehen von der Frage, ob er sich nun wirklich aus der Erde heraus getrennt hat oder ob er tatsächlich im Entstehungsprozess der Erde sich wiederum aus dem, woraus die Erde entstanden ist, auch schon mit entstanden ist. Eigentlich eine ähnliche Geschichte, kann man sagen. Also auch das war mal ein sehr heißer Körper, wo sich viel bewegt hat und wo es Vulkanismus gab und Magma, Meere etc., so wie es auf der Erde eigentlich auch war.
Ja, eigentlich umgedreht. Das hat man erst vom Mond gelernt und dann für die Erde anwenden können. Weil auf der Erde sind natürlich all diese Gesteine oder Schichten aus der Frühphase der Entstehung sind alle durch die Plattentechtonik verschwunden, überprägt, werden durch Verwitterung, durch sonstige Einfüsse völlig verändert. Das heißt, man hat hier eigentlich keine wirklichen Spuren auf der Erde aus der Frühphase. Alles, was so prekamprisch, ja im Endeffekt älter als 600, 700 Millionen Jahre ist, da wird schon langsam schwierig, irgendwelche Aussagen zu machen, wie sah es denn damals wirklich aus auf der Erde.
Alles zur Seite geräumt worden?
Ja, es ist vor allem dann auch in große Tiefen versenkt wurden, überprägt wurden, umgewandelt wurden, dann wieder hoch gekommen im Rahmen von Gebirgsbildung. Es sind sicherlich manche Sachen vorhanden, aber eben nur Relikte und deutlich überprägt verändert. Dagegen auf dem Mond hat man den großen Vorteil, wir können wirklich zurückschauen, was in der Frühphase passiert, denn der Mond hat eine vergleichsweise schnelle geologische Entwicklung durchlaufen. Er ist ein Einplattenkörper, also er besteht aus einer Kruste, aus einer Platte praktisch, es findet keine Platten-Tektonik statt, es finden keine großen Umformungen statt, so dass wirklich Materialien aus der Frühphase quasi unverändert untersucht werden könnten.
Aber wenn das auch mal so eine Magma-Welt war, warum hat sich das dann anders entwickelt als die Erde? Warum gibt es auf der Erde diese Tektonik und alles überstülpt sich und überprägt sich und warum ist der Mond so ein Langweiler geworden?
Langweiler möchte ich mal von der Hand weisen, er ist in Sicherheit kein Langweiler. Er ist anders. Das ist zum einen die Größe, er ist kleiner, dann Unterschiede in der Gesamtzusammensetzung, die Dichte zum Beispiel vom Mond, Gesamtdichte ist 3, noch was von der Erde über 5 Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter und es gibt also schon deutliche Unterschiede zwischen diesen beiden Objekten und eben die Erde hat sehr hohen volatile Anteile, also reich an Wasser. Die Erde hat ihre Atmosphäre behalten. Es ist ein Wechselspiel, was auf der Erde stattfindet zwischen Atmosphäre, Hydrosphäre und dem Erdinneren, wo ständig Dinge überarbeitet werden und sich gegenseitig auch antreiben und verändern, bis hin zu den biogenen Einflüssen, die auch ihren Einfluss nehmen auf das vulkanische Geschehen.
Also Pflanzen, Tiere etc. alles.
Biogenomaterialien, richtig. Die Bildung von Carbonaten, die dann wieder in Subduktionszonen verschwinden.
Ja, ist ja mächtig was los auf der Erde. Das ist natürlich beim Mond alles nicht. Das heißt, das hat dann sozusagen zu so einer Auskühlung geführt.
Das hat im Endeffekt zu einer Auskühlung geführt, das ist richtig. Man hat also die Bildung einer Kruste, es ist stark und Vulkanismus, der dann recht früh schon vermutlich eingesetzt hat, vor vier Milliarden Jahren oder älter. Gibt es inzwischen schon Anzeichen, die hat man am Anfang zu den Apollo-Zeiten eigentlich noch gar nicht entdeckt gehabt. Solch alten Vulkanismus kam erst später auf, bei neuerer Durchsicht der Proben und mit neueren Messungen eben schon angesprochen von Galileo. Das ist hier wirklich einen Vulkanismus gibt, der deutlich älter ist, wie dieser schon mit bloßem Auge erkennbare Mare-Vulkanismus. Also Mare, noch mal nennt man die Regionen, die dunklen Regionen, die ursprüngliche Impactbecken waren, die dann von basalten, vulkanischen Basalten geflutet sind.
Das heißt, als irgendwas eingeschlagen hat, ein dickes Loch gemacht?
Hat ein dickes Loch gemacht, ja, aber dann hat es noch eine ganze Weile gedauert. Dadurch waren Wegbarkeiten geschaffen für ein Magma, das dann später irgendwann seinen Weg nach oben gefunden hat.
Weil da einfach so eine fragile Stelle war.
Weil da eine fragile Stelle war, wo dann das Magma aufdrängen konnte.
Dann hat es geblubbert.
Aber es gab eben auch schon älteren Vulkanismus, deutlich älter als vier Milliarden Jahre diesen sogenannten Creep-Vulkanismus, der eben eine andere chemische Zusammensetzung hat. Also seltene Erden, reichern seltenen Erden an Phosphor, an Kalium.
Aber jetzt ist es doch auch so, dass so ein Vulkanismus unter anderem auch dadurch ausgelöst werden kann, dass eben starke Gravitationen auf diesen Körper wirken. Nun dreht sich ja der Mond regelmäßig um die Erde, einmal im Monat, daher der Name. Und könnte man nicht erwarten, dass dieser permanente Einfluss der Erde mit ihrer relativ starken Gravitation diesen Mond nicht flüssig halten könnte? Dass er so die ganze Zeit durchgerührt wird?
Also er wird mit Sicherheit durchgerührt und er wurde in der Frühphase oder früher deutlich kräftiger durchgerührt, denn auf Grunde des Wechselspiels der Gezeitenkräfte zwischen Erde und Mond entfernt sich ja der Mond langsam und allmählich, so derzeit mit etwa 40 Millimetern pro Jahr von der Erde. Ach echt? Und dadurch wird gleichzeitig die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit der Erde langsamer. Also früher, die Dinosaurier hatten eher, naja, etwas knapp über 20 Stunden Tag. Heute sind wir bei 24 Stunden. Und da waren natürlich die Gezeitenkräfte deutlich stärker. Und es gibt nach eben gerade neueren Messungen, es gab ja jetzt neue Missionen in den 90er Jahren und eben dieses Jahr 1000, gibt es geophysikalische Messungen, also des Magnetfeldes, aber auch der schwere Messungen, die darauf hindeuten, dass es vielleicht doch eine zumindest zum Teil aufgeschmolzene Zone im Mondinneren gibt.
Immer noch?
Immer noch. Richtig. Und da könnten natürlich Gezeitenkräfte, könnten plus Restwärme, könnten eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Aber das reicht alles nicht mehr aus, um jetzt wirklich irgendeinen Vulkanismus noch anzustoßen, also der sich jetzt wirklich auf der Oberfläche durchschlägt.
Also die jüngsten vulkanischen Ablagerungen, die man kennt und deren Alter man aufgrund von Kraterzählungen abschätzt, sind etwa 1 Milliarde, 1,2 Milliarden Jahre alt. Danach hat man eigentlich keine vulkanischen Ablagerungen erkannt in den bisherigen Daten. Und es gibt, sagen wir mal so, Hinweise, also Messungen zum Beispiel von Radon, Osmonium, also seltenen Elementen, die auf der Erde typisch sind in einer spätvulkanischen Phase. Also wenn der Vulkanismus quasi aufgehört hat, dass dann noch solche Engasungen kommen. Da hat schon Apollo mal erste Messungen durchgeführt und was nachgewiesen. Und daraufhin wurde eben spekuliert, es könnte noch eine gewisse Restaktivität in einem späthytrothermal, naja, wobei wir haben ja eigentlich kein Wasser, oder so war die Annahme zumindest. Eine sehr späte Phase des Vulkanismus könnte dort noch stattfinden. Es ging dann hin bis zur Spekulation, dass es möglicherweise zu wirklichen solchen Ausgasungen kommt, also in größeren Mengen solches Gase entweichen können, die zum einen durch radioaktiven Zerfall von Kalium entstehen und zum anderen eben solche Ausgasungsprozesse, die dann zu Hohlformen führen könnten.
Unter dem Mantel?
Nein, an der Oberfläche.
Wenn man jetzt zum Mond fliegt, also die Sache mit den Weltraumtaxis wäre jetzt schon Realität, man steigt da irgendwie ein. Worauf müsste man sich einstellen? Also wie ist es da? Keine Atmosphäre, schon klar Sauerstoff, etc. Luft zum Atmen sollte man definitiv selber mitführen. Man ist natürlich mangels einer Atmosphäre, da auch ganz anderen Bedingungen des Universums ausgesetzt. Aber wie präsentiert sich das? Ich meine, man kennt natürlich jetzt so die Bilder. Ich hätte jetzt so die Erwartung, dass ist da so eine staubige, schmutzige Umgebung und man sollte aufpassen, dass man Klamotten trägt, wo das Zeug da nicht so schnell reinkommt. Ist das eine realistische Sicht der Dinge?
Das ist eine realistische Sicht der Dinge. Der Mondboden oder Regolith, wie man auch sagt, hat so in etwa eine mittlere Korngröße von 60 bis 80 Mikrometer. Das ist also wirklich so zählt wie Staub, würde man auf der Erde dazu sagen. Er ist natürlich unsortiert. Es geht dann bis zu Zentimetergroßen und noch größeren Brocken. Es geht aber auch zu ganz feinem Material, wenige Mikrometer bis unter den Nanometer groß. Und das Zeug ist sehr adhensiv. Das haben ja schon die Astronauten feststellen müssen, wenn sie dann in ihre Landefähre zurückgekehrt sind. Die sahen also aus, als ob sie sich im Dreck gewälzt hatten und Fußball gespielt hatten. Und man musste wirklich aufpassen, dass dieser Staub sich nicht in die Systeme innerhalb der Landefähre irgendwo einschleicht und dort dann zu Schädigungen führt. Also der Staub an der Mondoberfläche ist sicherlich ein großes Problem. Wenn sie zum Beispiel einen kilogroßen Brocken an der Oberfläche nehmen, dann wird er durch sogenannte Mikrometeoritenimpakte, also durch Einschläge von kleinen Staubkörnern innerhalb von von zehn Millionen Jahren völlig zerrieben. Und das ist momentan auch der eigentlich der große geologische Prozess, der sicherlich nur an der Oberfläche aktiv ist. Das ist eben diese Verwitterung im Weltraum, die Wechselwirkung mit der Weltraumumgebung. Das ist zum einen Staubpartikel, die doch immer wieder anzutreffen sind. Mikrometeorite, die einschlagen, sei es nun Material von Asteroiden oder von Kometen oder interplanetarer Staub, die doch immerhin mit einer Menge von zehn Millionen Kilo quasi pro Jahr auf die Oberfläche einschlagen.
Zehn Millionen Kilogramm Staub ein Schlag, sozusagen, aber das meiste davon wirklich kleiden.
Macht nichts.
Ist trotzdem schnell.
Keine Atmosphäre, das heißt...
15 bis 18 Kilometer pro Sekunde im Mittel, im Extremfall bis zu 70 Kilometer pro Sekunde, wie es da drauf drinnen kann. Also da, das dringt so gut wie überall durch.
Das heißt, während die Astronauten da auf der Oberfläche standen, waren sie sehr wohl der Gefahr ausgesetzt, von irgendwas getroffen zu werden oder ist das jetzt dann doch sehr wahrscheinlich?
Naja, doch. Es bestand die Gefahr, von etwas getroffen zu werden. Dass es etwas Größeres ist, was zu größeren Schädigungen führt, ist natürlich nicht so wahrscheinlich, aber man muss sich davor schützen. Und deswegen ist ja auch immer die Idee, wenn man denn den Mond besiedeln möchte, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, das heißt eine Forschungsstation wie Antarktis, dass man da eine dicke Schutzschicht bauen muss, eine Schutzkuppel, unter der man sich verstecken kann. Eben zum einen vor solchen einschlagenden Mikrometeoriten, aber eben auch vor dem Sonnenwind, der ja völlig ungestört auf die Oberfläche treffen kann. Mit Ausnahme, wenn jetzt der Mond durch das Magnetfeld der Erde geht, also praktisch im Erdschatten ist, von der Sonne aus gesehen. Aber ansonsten kann der Sonnenwind, also Protonenstrahlung, Partikelstrahlung hochenergetischer Natur direkt auf die Oberfläche treffen. Und das ist natürlich nicht besonders gesundheitsfördernd.
Das heißt, der Mond hat kein eigenes Magnetfeld?
Er hat kein eigenes Magnetfeld. Es gibt einen sogenannten remanenten Magnetismus. Remanenter Magnetismus sind ganz, also ich versuche es vielleicht anders zu erklären. Wenn vulkanisches Material Magma erstatt abkühlt und dann ab einer gewissen Temperatur und einem Magnetfeld unterworfen ist, dann ab einer gewissen Temperatur orientieren sich die sich bildenden Kristalle gemäß der Magnetfeldlinien aus. Und da Mondmaterial doch eher eisenreich ist und auch häufig titanhaltig, kann es eben dazu kommen, dass dann hier ein remanenter Magnetismus entsteht. Also praktisch das Gestein eine schwach magnetisierende Wirkung hat. Und das kann man auch messen aus dem Weltraum. Und da hat man mehrere Regionen auf dem Mond, wo eben so etwas auftritt. Und da ist dann auch sogar das überraschende, das haben jetzt die letzten Missionen zum Beispiel der Inder gezeigt mit dem schwedischen Instrument, also die Mission Schandrayan. Die konnten deutlich zeigen, dass hier die Wechselwirkung an der Oberfläche zwischen Sonnenwind und Mond-Oberfläche in diesen Bereichen, wo noch so ein remanenter Magnetismus vorhanden ist, etwas anders ist, wie in den Bereichen, wo man solch ein remanentes Magnetfeld nicht hat.
Also nicht weniger, sondern anders.
Also es erscheinen anscheinend diese geladenen Wasserstoffkerne, Wasserstoffprotonen scheinen abgelenkt zu werden und nicht so sehr auf die Oberfläche einzutreffen, wie eben in den Bereichen, in denen kein remanentes Magnetfeld ist.
Das heißt, die optimale Mondbasis wäre eigentlich so eine riesige Glaskuppel, die auch noch ihr eigenes Magnetfeld erzeugt.
Das wäre nicht ungünstig.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so einfach zu bauen.
Aber wenn die Magnetkuppel, pardon, wenn die die Betonkuppel oder Glaskuppel, eher ein Baton, Glas vielleicht nicht ganz, Betonkuppel dick genug ist, dann wird auch der Sonnenwind abgehalten werden können.
Wie dick müsste der denn so sein? Unklar. Dick. Aber da kann man natürlich nicht mehr so schön ins All gucken. Wo bleibt da die Romantik? Glaskuppel wäre natürlich schöner.
Ja, ein paar Fenster wird man ja noch sicherlich einbauen können.
Ja, aber da sind wir auch schon wieder so bei diesem Ur-Science-Fiction-Traum. Ich glaube, so Glaskuppel war da auf die auch schon relativ früh immer am Start, wenn man es über eine Mondbasis nachgedacht hat. Weil wenn man schon da oben ist, dann wird man natürlich auch einen guten Blick haben. Bleiben wir nochmal kurz auf der Oberfläche. Also ist alles extrem staubig in unterschiedlichen Körnungen. Alles, was da rumliegt, wird über kurz oder lang von dem permanent aufschlagenden Staub zermahlen, sodass die Tendenz an der Oberfläche ist, eigentlich irgendwann ist es alles nur noch Staub. Also egal, was da jetzt noch an größeren Strukturen rumliegt, dass es dann über kurz oder lang vom Weltall zersägt wird. Also es bildet sich ja nichts Neues mehr, es schlägt mal wieder irgendwas Dickes auf.
Eben. Das haben sie natürlich permanent. Sie haben ja permanent größere Einschläge, die stattfinden und dann Neues, gröberes, unverwidertes Material an die Oberfläche transportieren. Schaffen können, sieht man ja auch zum Beispiel diese Strahlenkrater, die man von der Erde aus so schön sieht, diese hellen Strahlen, die da zum Beispiel von Tycho ausgehen und die man im Teleskop sehr toll sieht, jetzt eigentlich sogar mit dem bloßen Auge. Das ist eben ein relativ junger Krater, Tycho, vermutlich 800 Millionen Jahre um den Dreh. Und da sind diese Strahlen, sind eben unverwidertes Material, was ausgeworfen wurde, weit verteilt wurde und eben deutlich heller ist, wie das Umfeld. Also diese Mikrometeoritenimpakte, die führen wirklich nicht nur zu einer mechanischen Zerrüttung, sondern die führen auch zu einer chemischen Veränderung, also zum Teil zu einer Aufschmelzung, dass sich Glaspartikel bilden, nennt man dann Agglutinate, bis hin zu einer, dass metallisches Eisen entstehen kann und dieses metallische Eisen in einer Nanometergröße sorgt dafür, dass dann das Material dunkler wird, wohingegen helles Material eher für frisches Mondmaterial, Mondgestein, spricht. Aber durch diese Impactprozesse kommen eben immer wieder neue Gesteine an die Oberfläche, es entstehen auch steile Wände, an denen natürlich dann zum Beispiel Basalddecken angeschnitten werden können und eben auch hier Gesteine anstehen. Da hat ja jetzt die amerikanische Mission Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter mit seiner sehr hochauflösenden Kamera im Dezimeterbereich ganz tolle Aufnahmen von solchen Basaldschichten in Kratern gezeigt oder in solchen Rillen, also eingestürzten Lava-Kanälen, die doch sehr deutlich machen, dass es noch immer dort auch Gesteine, anstehendes Gestein gibt.
Jetzt, wenn wir so landen mit einem Taxi, also das Gefühl kenn ich schon mal. Ich war ja hier für Raumzeit auch schon mal in einem Parabelflug unterwegs, der dann freundlicherweise auch in der ersten Parabel gleich mit der Erdschwere daher kam. Also eine leicht abgeändert Parabel, die dann eben mir genau die Gravitation geboten hat, wenn auch nur für 22 Sekunden, wie sie eben auf dem Mond herrscht. Da konnte man dann sozusagen live dieses Astronautengehopse, was man so schön kennt aus den Bildern der Landung, gut nachvollziehen. Wenn man da einen ordentlichen Sprung nimmt, dann ist man da ganz gut unterwegs, so auf dem Mond. Wie weit müsste man denn jetzt gehen, bis sich das dann ändert? Also ich meine, gibt es jetzt wirklich unterschiedliche Regionen, wo der Mond dann auf einmal anders ist, deutlich anders ist, oder ist eigentlich überall alles gleich und auch die Helle und die Dunkel, also die uns zugewandte und die abgewandte Seite ist weitgehend identisch?
Nein, da gibt es deutliche Unterschiede. Also die Schwere, die 17 Prozent Schwerkraft im Vergleich zur Erde, das haben sie überall auf dem Mond. Da wird sich nicht groß etwas ändern, zumindest nicht für das menschliche Empfinden. Für Messsonden, die um den Mond herumfliegen, sicherlich ist da was nachweisbar. Und es ist ja gerade hier eine Sonde unterwegs mit Grail von den Amerikanern, die versucht, das Schwerefeld sehr detailliert noch mal zu vermessen. Aber ansonsten gibt es deutliche Unterschiede zwischen der Mondvorderseite und der Mondrückseite. Sie haben zum Beispiel auf der Mondvorderseite sind 30 Prozent der Oberfläche dunkles Maramaterial, also vulkanisches Material. Wenn wir den gesamten Mond nehmen, nehmen solche vulkanischen Materialien eigentlich nur 17 Prozent der gesamten Fläche ein. Das heißt, auf der Mondrückseite habe ich deutlich mehr sogenannte Hochländer, helle Hochländer, felspartreiche Hochländer, die also aus sehr frühen Phasen der Mondentwicklung stammen. Wir haben genauso eigentlich auf der Mondrückseite die größten Höhenunterschiede. Wir haben unten im Süden vorwiegend aber auf der Mondrückseite mit dem South Pole-Aidken-Basin das größte Einschlagsbecken im Sonnensystem mit einem Durchmesser von 2500 Kilometern etwa, das zwar auch ein bisschen dunkler ist wie die Umgebung, aber eben völlig anders wie diese vulkanischen Marebecken. Auch in seiner Zusammensetzung, das in etwa eine Tiefe hat von über 9 Kilometern unter Normal-0 auf dem Mond. Und gleichzeitig gibt es in den Hochlandregionen dort die größte Höhe von 11-12 Kilometern.
Das heißt sehr viel größere Höhenunterschiede auf der Erde?
Nee, vergleichbare Höhenunterschiede auf der Erde. Hier auf der Erde haben wir dann 12.000 Meter Mariengraben und 8.000, 9.000 plus, also das ist vergleichbar. Aber immerhin, ich meine, der Mond ist deutlich kleiner als die Erde, also die gesamte Oberfläche des Mondes ist etwa so groß wie Afrika und zeigt vergleichbare Höhenunterschiede.
Aber das ist alles Zufall, dass es jetzt auf der Rückseite so oder so ist. Es gibt da jetzt keine Eigenschaften, die da jetzt...
Das weiß man nicht so ganz genau, ob das alles Zufall ist oder nicht. Warum ausgerechnet diese der Erde zugewandte Seite, besonders viel Marebasalde-Aufweis könnte natürlich auch mit der Erde zusammenhängen. Vielleicht aber auch nicht. Man hat auf der Mondrückseite ist die größte um 15 Kilometer im Mittel dicker wie auf der Vorderseite. Also es gibt schon eindeutige Unterschiede. Warum das nun so genau ist, ist noch ein Gebiet der Forschung mit mehreren Hypothesen.
Jetzt klang ja vorhin schon an, es ist Wasser gefunden worden. Jetzt nicht unbedingt in der Form, wie man das jetzt hier so erwarten würde, dass auf einmal so ein See da herumliegt, in dem man schön baden kann. Aber das war lange Zeit unklar, ob sich überhaupt Wasser auf dem Mond befindet. Wodurch ist man dem dann auf die Spur gekommen?
Also da gibt es zwei Dinge, wenn wir mit der ersten Entdeckung anfangen, dann war das, es gab eigentlich schon Anfang der 70er Jahre, gab es theoretische Überlegungen, Modellierungen, die gesagt haben, in den Polbereichen, wenn ich permanent Schatten habe, können dort Temperaturen von etwa 40 Kelvin herrschen. Und dann entstehen hier so quasi Kältefallen, in denen sich von Kometen oder Asteroiden zum Mond gebrachtes Wasser oder Wassereis ansammeln könnte. Das würde dann quasi durch die Wechselwirkung mit der Sonne, mit der Bespralung, also mit dem Tag-Nacht-Zyklus quasi immer polwärts wandern, immer zu den kältesten Stellen und sich dann dort ansammeln.
Wandern?
Naja, ich meine, tagsüber wird es quasi gasförmig, dann kondensiert es wieder. Es wird nicht alles durch Fotodissoziation verloren und kann dann quasi in Kälte fallen, zu den kältesten Stellen einfach hintriften. Das war also eine Art theoretische Modellierung. Aber das war wie gesagt nur erst mal eine Modellierung, eine Annahme, die eigentlich von der Hand gewesen wurde.
Aber sind denn die Pole auch nicht dauerhaft dunkel?
Es gibt Bereiche, das haben eben die neueren Missionen gezeigt, die wirklich permanent im Schatten sind. Deswegen wollte ich jetzt auch auf die neueren Messungen eingehen. Es gab dann die ersten Anzeichen von der Clementine-Mission in den 90er Jahren. Die hat dann praktisch ihre Antenne, die sonst zur Telekommunikation verwendet wurde, also zum Übermitteln der Daten zur Erde, hat die praktisch auf die Mondoberfläche gerichtet, ein starkes Signal ausgesandt und dann hat man das vom Mond reflektierte Signal auf der Erde empfangen. Und da gab es deutliche Unterschiede vor allem am Südpol. Und dann war...
Also so eine Art Radar.
Exakt. Wie statisches Radar. Und das war dann eben von seinen Eigenschaften des empfangenden Signals ging man dann davon aus, da könnte ja eigentlich Wasser eis vorhanden sein. Und dann hat man danach fieberhaft gesucht. Luna Prospector.
Entschuldigung, was sieht man denn in diesem Signal, das auf Eis hinweist? Also was...
Naja, die Reflexionseigenschaft von Wasser eis ist komplett anders wie die von Gesteinsmaterial. Klar. Da konnte man etwas messen. Man hat dann versucht, von der Erde aus Messungen hinzumachen. Etwas ähnliches hat man auch bei Merkur gemacht. Bei Merkur ist man sich relativ sicher, dass es wirklich Wasser eis ist. Bei Mond kam dann wieder langsam Zweifel auf. Eine zweite Mission, die etwas in die Richtung gemessen hat, war Lunaprospektor. Die hatten einen Neutronendetektor, der von der Mond reflektiert oder ausgesandte Neutronen vermisst. Da hat eben Wasser, also Wasserstoff, nicht Wasser, sondern Wasserstoff, die Eigenschaft, dieses Signal deutlich zu dämpfen. Dieser Neutronendetektor hat eben deutlich gezeigt, dass an beiden Polen eine Wasserstoffanreicherung ist. Wasserstoff könnte vom Sonnenwind stammen. Da hat man ja die positiv geladenen Protonen. Wenn die Elektronen aufnehmen, dann ist es im Endeffekt Wasserstoff. Könnte also eingebrachter Sonnenwind sein oder eben auch Wassereis. Und hat man lange spekuliert, was es sein kann. Die ESA-Mission Smart1, auch andere haben und eben die neueren Missionen der Chinesen, der Inder, der Japaner und auch der Amerikaner haben dann versucht, wirklich kontinuierlich über einen Jahreszyklus zu vermessen, ob am Nord- und am Südpol zum einen permanent Schatten- zonen existieren, in tiefen Kratern und das konnte nachgewiesen werden. Das gibt's wirklich. In der Zwischenzeit kennt man auch die Temperaturen von dort. Die gehen eben bis 60-40 Grad Kelvin runter.
Also sehr kalt.
Sehr kalt. Es gab dann El Cross, ein Bestandteil oder ja von den Amerikanern quasi eine Art Impaktsonde, die vom Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter abgeworfen wurde. Man hat einen künstlichen Impakt erzeugt und dann die durch den Impakts entstanden ausgeworfenen Materialien, vorwiegend Gase natürlich, spektral vermessen und konnte dann wirklich nachweisen, okay hier ist Wassereis vorhanden an den Polen.
Das war dann der Beweis.
Das war dann der Beweis und das Zweite ist, es gibt dann auch Radarinstrumente, die das vermessen haben, wo man dann noch feststellen kann, sind das nun wirklich Wassereisflächen, wie man sie hier von den Polargebieten kennt oder im Winter her kennt oder ist es vielleicht nur etwas Wassereis vermischt mit dem Regolith und dadurch auch zum Teil geschützt, also mit dem Mondboden und darauf deutet es hin, dass da also etwas Wasser vorhanden ist an den Polen. Das ist die eine.
Also quasi mit diesem Mondstaub vermengtes Eis.
Richtig, insbesondere in den kühlen Regionen. Da scheint gesichert zu sein. Wie genau die Prozesse sind, da wird noch viel spekuliert und ist auch noch sicherlich viel zu untersuchen und zu vermessen und hier wird angenommen, dass es eben vorwiegend Wasser, also dass dieses Wasser vorwiegend durch Impact, durch Einschläge von Kometen und von Asteroiden, von denen ja auch sehr viele wasserreich sein können, an die Mondoberfläche gebracht wird. Das zweite, was man gemessen hat von der Chandrayaan-Mission, einer indischen Mission, die ein abbildendes Spektrometer dabei hat, was eben auch die Wasserbanden vermessen kann. Da hat man plötzlich festgestellt, dass in Abhängigkeit von der Tageszeit fast überall auf dem Mond anscheinend eine ein Molekül-dicke Wasserschicht sich herausbilden kann, direkt an der Oberfläche, direkt oben am Boden und auch wieder verschwinden kann.
Ein Molekül.
Ganz dünn.
Wie kann man denn sowas messen?
Sie kriegen trotzdem eindeutige Banden von dem Wasser bei 3 Mikrometer. Das kann man dann schon nachweisen, wenn sie eben entsprechend empfindlich sind. Deswegen hat man das früher auch nicht gesehen. Es gab mal Spekulationen von der Cassini-Mission, die ähnlich wie Galileo auch einen Erdemond-Vorbeiflug gemacht hat. Da war auch so ein abbildender Spektrometer dabei. WIMS. Und ich kann mich noch gut an einen Vortrag erinnern, wo dann einer aus dem Wissenschaftsteam hier vorgestellt hat, es könnte Wassereis sein auf dem Mond. Alle haben gelacht und keiner hat es geglaubt. Und hier mit M-Cube, so heißt das Instrument auf der indischen Mission, ist aber ein amerikanisches Instrument, konnte das eben eindeutig nachgewiesen werden.
Warum haben alle gelacht? War das so abwegig?
Ja, das war so abwegig. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war eben der Mond wirklich noch einfach nur trocken.
Wasser.
Ohne Wasser, wasserfrei. Sowohl aus dem Inneren wie im Äußeren, vielleicht ein bisschen Wasser, als an den Pulen durch Kometa eingebracht, aber ansonsten durfte da kein Wasser sein.
Das heißt, das Lachen ist dann einem im Hals stecken geblieben.
In der Zwischenzeit sind alle hellauf begeistert, dass es doch was gibt. Man lernt ja dazu.
Wird wieder spannend.
Es wird wieder spannend. Ganz genau. Hier ist eben die Vermutung, dass dieser dünne Wasserfilm, der ja tageszeitabhängig ist, also sprich abhängig von der Einstrahlungsintensität, von der Wärme, dass der durch eine Wechselwirkung zwischen den Protonen des Sonnenwindes, also H+, und dem Mondboden entsteht. Also zum einen kann ja durch Aufnahme eines Elektrons H entstehen und dann brauchen sie noch Sauerstoff und Sauerstoff haben sie eigentlich genügend in den silikatischen Mineralien vorhanden, dass da dann eben ein dünner Wasserfilm entstehen kann. Das ist die zweite spannende Frage, wie sieht das genau aus, was geht da vor?
Und der ist aber immer nur für kurze Zeit da. Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Die Morgentau oder?
Die Morgentau oder Abentau, reif oder wie auch immer, möglich. Also es gibt eine deutliche Tageszeitabhängigkeit und bei hohen Sonnenständen ist er weg. Es gibt auch anscheinend eine Breitenabhängigkeit, aber leider Shantrayan ist nicht mehr in Betrieb. Also war nur wenige Monate in Betrieb, war sehr erfolgreich, aber eben nur wenige Monate in Betrieb. Da fehlen einfach die Daten, um da nähere Aussagen zu machen. Und jetzt noch das Dritte, wo Wasser entdeckt wurde, ist völlig unabhängig von diesen direkten Missionen, sondern es hängt einfach mit der Analytik, mit den analytischen Methoden im Labor zusammen. Da hat man natürlich auf der Erde große Fortschritte gemacht in den Labors. Man kann, was weiß ich, Part per Million, Part per Billion oder sonst irgendwas kann man in der Zwischenzeit messen. Und da ist man eben wieder an die Mondproben hergegangen, von denen man ausging, die sind nur trocken. Man hat dort in vulkanischen Gläsern, wo man also ganz sicher sein kann, dass das keine Kontamination von der Erde her ist, also keine Verunreinigung durch den Transport zur Erde oder auf der Erde.
Also die wurden schon auf dem Mond quasi in Glas eingeschlossen?
Die sind quasi auf dem Mond hermetisch in Glas eingeschlossen worden. Und da hat man eben Wasser an Appetit festgestellt oder zum Teil auch OH-Mineralien, was ebenfalls eine Art Revolution bedeutet. Das heißt, vermutlich hat auch der Mond das Mondinnere, das heißt, der Mond per se hat Wasser enthalten.
Das heißt, der Mond ist eigentlich nass, es hat bloß bis dahin keiner gemerkt.
Er ist vergleichsweise trocken, aber er ist nasser, wie gedacht, es hat keiner gemerkt.
Interessant. So wie so ein Waschlappen, der irgendwie noch nicht ganz ausgetrocknet ist, aber schon so ein bisschen einigstig Eindruck macht, er wäre es. Wie jeder Vergleich. Ja, aber es ist ja erstaunlich. Also das heißt, umso mit besseren Instrumenten man hinschaut und mit mehr Missionen man auch irgendwie bestimmte Aspekte, die man vielleicht bisher links liegen gelassen hat, drauf schaut, merkt man, dass eigentlich in diesem auf den ersten Blick sehr langweiligen Mondstaub doch eine ganze Menge mehr zu holen ist, als man dachte. Gibt es denn irgendeine konkrete Vorstellung davon, um welche Mengen Wasser es sich dabei handelt?
Die gibt's, die kann ich aber leider nicht nennen.
Ja, aber es ist schon signifikant. Es ist jetzt nicht so, so, ah jetzt haben wir da auch mal ein bisschen Wasser gefunden, sondern es ist schon so, dass ich abzeichne, dass zumindest in diesen Polregionen das irgendwie nennenswerte Mengen sind.
Ja, allein schon diese Spekulation über mögliches Wassereis an den Polen hat also die Ingenieurenherze höher schlagen lassen und Träume von möglichst nah am Pol landen. Zum einen haben wir da, wenn es dort die Bereiche mit permanentem Schatten gibt, gibt es dort die Bereiche natürlich auch mit quasi permanenter Sonne. Das heißt, wir kriegen immer Energie von der Sonne und nebenan können wir unsere Leitungen legen in den Krater rein und holen unser Wasser dort raus. Die sind natürlich angestachelt worden jetzt durch die neueren Funde, dass eben Wasser auch durch Wechselwirkungen mit dem Sonnenwind entstehen kann. Vielleicht lassen sich hier Möglichkeiten finden, den Sonnenwind quasi zu nutzen. Da sind sicherlich die Spekulationen im Gange. Die Ingenieure sind da sehr, finde ich.
Sonnenwindkraftwerke.
Kraftwerke wohl kaum. Man will ja das Wasser. Man braucht das Wasser.
Wozu braucht man denn das Wasser?
Das Wasser brauchen sie zum Leben. Entweder sie müssen es mitbringen. Wenn sie bemannt dort sein wollen, dann brauchen sie es. Genau darum dreht sich es. Und sie brauchen ihn natürlich als Treibstoff. Wasser ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil von Raketentreibstoffen. Wenn man also in fantastische Zukunftsregionen vorgeht, wo man möglicherweise vom Mond aus mit großen Missionen starten könnte, dann wäre natürlich Wasser ein wichtiger Bestandteil für den Treibstoff.
Also wenn man quasi sich, dann setzen wir schon jenseits der Mondbasis hin zum Raketen-Startplatz, der gegenüber der Erde den Vorteil hätte, dass man mit deutlich weniger Energie sich vom Mond lösen konnte.
Na zumindest kann man vom Mond her das Wasser viel leichter in den Weltraum bekommen, denn von der Erde.
Das heißt, dieser Mond, der umkreist uns, ich finde es immer schön, sich auch mal klar zu machen, wie weit er eigentlich weg ist. Dieses schöne Spiel mit dem Telesball und dem Basketball. Wenn man mal Leute fragt, wie weit die eigentlich voneinander entfernt sein müssten, um das Verhältnis zwischen Mond und Erde auszudrücken, da kann man dann immer viel Aha-Momente erleben. Ich lasse es jetzt an dieser Stelle mal offen, kann man jeder selber nachmessen.
384.000 Kilometer.
Ja, also es ist ja in astronomischen Dimensionen, ist ja wirklich um die Ecke, aber es hat trotzdem noch einiges Stück zu gehen. Was kann man jetzt noch lernen von dem Mond über den Rest des Universums und wo war jetzt sozusagen der Mond lehrreich oder könnte auch noch künftig lehrreich sein für die Erforschung unseres Sonnensystems und vielleicht auch darüber hinaus?
Nach wie vor gerade jetzt auch mit den neuen Erkenntnissen zur Zusammensetzung des Mondes, worüber wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, die Fernerkundungsdaten zeigen, dass es auf dem Mond eine Vielfalt an Gesteinsvarianten gibt, unterschiedlichen Gesteinstypen, von denen wir noch überhaupt keine Proben auf der Erde haben. Das heißt, da ist also noch eine große Diversität vorhanden an der Mondoberfläche, die es wert ist, untersucht zu werden und die eben Einblick gibt in die Frühphasen eines silikatreichen Planeten, so wie es die Erde ist. Wie entstehen Planeten? Wie bilden sie sich? Wie bildet sich die Kruste? Kommt es wirklich zu einer Magmaozeanbildung? Da wäre der Mond und Mondproben eigentlich der Schluss dafür. Wie sieht es mit der Kernentstehung aus? Man vermutet ja oder neuere Daten deuten darauf hin, dass der Mond jetzt wirklich einen Kern hat. Es war lange Zeit debattiert. Die Sicherheit wird vermutlich die Grail-Mission dann liefern, wenn sie ihre Messungen abgeschlossen hat. Aber man geht davon aus, dass es wirklich im Inneren einen Kern doch gibt. Ist es wirklich so typisch? Kern, Mantel, Kruste, dieser Schalenaufbau für alle Planeten. Auch da ist der Mond ein wichtiges Beispiel für uns. Und als drittes, wir haben hier in nächster Nähe einen großen Körper ohne Atmosphäre, der uns umkreist und der permanent misst und aufzeichnet, was um ihn herum passiert, über die Geschichte seit seiner Entstehung. Das heißt, es ist praktisch, ja, es ist im Endeffekt eine Art Messsonde. Man hat viel Geld bezahlt, um mit dem Space Shuttle zum Beispiel irgendwelche metallischen Platten in den Weltraum zu bringen. Die hat man nach einem Jahr wieder runtergebracht und nachgeguckt, wie viel Strahlung, wie viele Teilchen sind da eingeschlagen. Der Mond fliegt da und er fliegt da schon seit Jahrmillionen, ja, eigentlich schon Jahrmilliarden und macht das. Und er macht das nicht nur von kosmischen Teilchen, sondern insbesondere auch von der Sonne. Und durch diese permanenten Impact-Prozesse werden natürlich immer wieder Auswurfsmaterialien nach einer gewissen Zeit quasi versiegelt von der Wechselwirkung mit dem Umfeld. Wenn man hier gezielt Proben entnimmt, kann man sicherlich sehr viel über die Sonne lernen, allein aus dem eingeschlossenen Sonnenwindpartikeln, die da drin liegen. Also er ist eigentlich eine Art Messsonde, die da rumfliegt und die über seine gesamte Geschichte hinweg Informationen gesammelt hat. Wir müssen sie nur noch dechiffrieren.
Jetzt klang er schon anfangs an. Einerseits gab es diese Hochphase in den 60er Jahren, das gipfelte dann eben in den Landungen von Menschen. Dann ist es ein bisschen ruhiger geworden und der Besuch des Mondes war eher noch ein Abfallprodukt zum Schwung holen, um noch sehr viel weiterzukommen. Jetzt gibt es aber, es sind auch schon einige Namen gefallen hier, darum gibt es zahlreiche neue Missionen, die angestrengt worden sind, die bereits noch in Operationen sind, die noch laufen, die auch schon abgeschlossen wurden. Was sind jetzt genau diese wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen, die wir jetzt hier gerade debattiert haben? Ist das so der primäre Grund oder ist es jetzt einfach nur, weil jetzt auch China und Indien dabei sind, dass der Mond einfach so ein wunderbares Startobjekt ist, um seine eigenen Weltraumtechnologien überhaupt erst mal zu entwickeln?
Beides. Also diese wissenschaftlichen Zielsetzungen sind sicherlich auch ein Treiber dafür, dass man zum Mond fliegt und dass man den Mond untersucht. Das Zweite ist natürlich, dass man den Mond als nächstgelegenen Körper nutzen möchte, um die Erkundung des Weltraums, sprich Flug zum Mars, vielleicht vorzubereiten durch die Erprobung von Technologien. Bei China und Indien spielt, vermutlich auch bei Japan, spielen sicherlich auch andere Gedanken eine Rolle, die eher so in die Frühphase der amerikanisch-sovietischen......ist erst mal geschafft zu haben... .ist erst mal geschafft zu haben, dort hinzufliegen. Es gibt auch sicherlich, möchte ich gar nicht so sehr drauf eingehen, es gibt da noch die Idee des Helium 3 Plus, was man auf dem Mond finden kann in größeren Mengen, was dann in Wasserstoffreaktoren quasi genutzt werden könnte, sollte man dann diese Technik überhaupt beherrschen. Das ist für manche sicherlich auch noch ein Hintergedanke.
Aber ist das jetzt eine Vermutung, dass es das dann gibt oder man?
Nein, das weiß man, dass es das gibt. Aber ob der wirklich genutzt werden kann, sei dahingestellt. Es wird drüber debattiert und die Technologie beherrscht man auch nicht. Also von daher ist das noch Zukunftsmusik, aber in manchen Köpfen spielt das sicherlich eine gewisse Rolle. Und ich meine, die Chinesen haben ganz klar ein Programm formuliert, dass die bemannt auf den Mond fliegen wollen und dort auch eine Station einrichten wollen und so wie man die Chinesen kennt werden, die das auf lange Sicht auch sicherlich durchführen. Auch die Inder haben ein sehr ehrgeiziges Projekt. Sie hatten Shantrayaan 1, der geflogen ist, Mond erreicht hat. Auch dort war so eine kleine Sonde, die auf den Mond eingeschlagen hat. Die wollen demnächst auch. Shantrayaan 2 ist in Vorbereitung. Also die sind aktiv dabei. Die Japaner hatten mit Kaguya eine sehr erfolgreiche Mission mit sehr vielen Instrumenten, die den Mond umkreist hat. Auch hier, da spricht man von Selene 2, eine Landung angedacht auf der Oberfläche. Die Amerikaner hatten ebenfalls zur Vorbereitung zukünftig der Landung den Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter gestartet, der immer noch in Betrieb ist, also fast die einzige Mission, die noch in Betrieb ist seit längerem und wertvolle Daten liefert. Sie haben parallel dazu mit GRAIL eine Mission, bestehend aus zwei Sonden, um das Schwerefeld des Mondes detailliert zu untersuchen, die jetzt quasi Anfang des Jahres den Mond erreicht hat. Und da dauert halt, dauert es eine ganze Weile, bis diese Daten dann wirklich gesammelt sind, so dass man ausreichend oder genügend Daten hat, um das wirklich auszuwerten. Und die Amerikaner haben auch noch mit LADIS eine Mission geplant, die vermutlich 2014 starten soll. Das ist auch eine vergleichsweise kleine Mission, die dann insbesondere die Exosphäre des Mondes untersuchen soll. Also der Mond, auch wenn man sagt, er hat keine Atmosphäre, so hat er doch eine sogenannte Exosphäre. Sprich, da sind so wenig Teilchen, dass sie nicht miteinander wechselwirken. Aber es sind doch so um die 10.000 Kilogramm, die da um den Mond herum fliegen an Atomen, an Molekülen.
Die da einfach so von der Gravitation noch gehalten werden?
Nee, die werden eigentlich immer wieder vermutlich entweder eingefangene Sonnwintteilchen oder reflektierte Sonnwintteilchen, die durch eine gewisse Zeit in die Mondgravitations Einfluss geraten oder eben von der Mondoberfläche herausgeworfene Teilchen. Man kennt zum Beispiel Natriumatome, Kaliumatome, die quasi vom Oberflächenmaterial natürlich stammen und durch diesen Sonnenwind, durch Wechselwirkung mit dem Sonnenwind erst erzeugt werden und hier in die Exosphäre hinauskommen. Also das will man dort genauer untersuchen und das Staubumfeld um den Mond herum. Ja und ansonsten danach haben eigentlich nur die Chinesen, die Inder und die Japaner engagierte Programme. Die ESA, die ja, ich glaube, am heutigen Tage gegründet wurde, irgendwann in den 70er Jahren. Wenn ich das richtig gesehen hatte vorhin in der S-Bahn.
Stimmt.
Die hat die beabsichtigt oder hat Pläne für eine mögliche Landemission. Die hat man schon in einer Vorphase untersucht und die Durchführbarkeit nachgewiesen, dass man so eine Mission machen kann. Und jetzt geht man da ein bisschen weiter und guckt, welche Instrumente könnte man draufbringen, wer hat Interesse in Europa. Das sind sicherlich Ideen, aber da ist noch nichts entschieden, ob Europa wirklich noch mal einen Schritt zum Mond macht nach seiner Smart-1-Mission oder nicht. Das ist noch ein Prozess, der diskutiert wird.
Trotzdem ist immer irgendwie viel los, auch so in diesem recht frischen Bereich der ganzen privaten Forschung. Es gibt zahlreiche Projekte, wo ermuntert wird, Mond-Landungs- oder Mondroboter zu bauen. Genau. Der Lunar X-Prize ist ein Beispiel. Man merkt glaube ich daran, dass schon der Mond schon so als erreichbares Ziel, auch gerade weil man weiß, man war da schon mal, das alles schon mal irgendwie gemacht worden. Vor 50 Jahren war es einfach ein ein riesen Aufwand. Mittlerweile hat sich die Raumfahrtechnik so weit entwickelt, dass man auch so aus dem privaten Umfeld heraus große Raketen starten kann. Gerade vor einigen Tagen hat es stattgefunden mit der Falcon 9 Rakete von SpaceX, sodass...
Wobei die wird ja von der NASA finanziert.
Jaja, das ist nicht vollkommen losgelöst und natürlich ist der gesamte Raumfahrtkomplex natürlich eine gar nicht so einfach zu übersehende Vermischung von privaten und staatlich getragenen Organisationen. Trotz alledem auch, sagen wir mal so, für den Hobbyforscher sind natürlich solche Gedankenspiele auch immer eine große Herausforderung. Gerade so dieser Gedanke, man ist jetzt auf dem Mond und hat seinen eigenen Rover und kann ihn dann durch diese Staubwüste führen. Um jetzt vielleicht noch mal kurz auch ganz an den Anfang zu kommen, jetzt konkret im Institut für Planetenforschung, was hält einen da am Thema Mond vor allem dran? Beobachtet man jetzt mehr sowas so allgemein an Informationen gesammelt wird und macht sich so seine Gedanken oder gibt es da auch noch bestimmte, konkretere Forschungsziele, wo man versucht, Erkenntnisse zu liefern?
Also Kollegen von mir, ich selber jetzt nicht, aber Kollegen von mir, insbesondere von der Abteilung für Planetengeodesie, die sind direkt an der Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter Mission beteiligt, an der Auswertung der Daten, insbesondere an der dreidimensionalen Auswertung der Kameradaten und auch der Laserdaten. Ebenfalls Kollegen waren beteiligt an der japanischen Kaguya Mission, an dem Laser Altimeter der Japaner. Und da laufen natürlich die Auswertungen der Daten einfach noch weiter. Und es gibt Projekte dann auch in Zusammenarbeit mit der Technischen Universität hier in Berlin und mit russischen Einrichtungen, dass man versucht nachzuvollziehen, wo zum Beispiel der Lunochord, die Rover wirklich gefahren sind, dass man versucht diese Strecken zu kartieren mit den neuesten Daten und genau zu vermessen. Also hier laufen wirklich aktive Forschungsarbeiten, auch in Vorbereitung auf die Zukunft. Wenn Mond-Daten vorhanden sind, dann guckt man die an, allein schon aus vergleichenden Gründen mit anderen Planeten, gerade zum Beispiel mit Merkur, der ja auch zumindest vom äußeren Anschein eine ähnliche Oberfläche hat. Auch da sind Kollegen beteiligt an der Messingermission oder wir bereiten uns vor auf die BepiColombo-Mission. Da ist natürlich dann der Mond immer ein geeignetes Vergleichsobjekt, insbesondere für vergleichende Analysen der fotogäologische Analysen der Oberfläche. Von daher ist er sicherlich auch bei uns noch sehr intensiv untersucht und wir würden natürlich gerne uns auch an irgendwelchen Missionen beteiligen, sofern sich uns die Möglichkeiten eröffnen.
Ja, haben wir noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Was es noch zum Mond zu sagen gibt?
Was heißt ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Ich meine, er ist einfach, er ist ja eigentlich permanent in unserem Bewusstsein. Schon als kleine Kinder sehen wir ihn vor uns, wir hören Lieder über ihn.
Der Mann im Mond.
Der Mann im Mond, die ganzen Geschichten, Jules Werm, der unsere Fantasien beflügelt hat. Ja, und es ist eigentlich schade, der Mond ist so nah und hat noch so viele offene Fragen zu liefern, die man einfach weiter verfolgen sollte.
Was heißt das auch, eigentlich auch ein super Thema für junge Wissenschaftler, dort einzusteigen?
Definitiv, ja. Also ich habe angesprochen, es sind weltraumfahrende Nationen, die intensiv den Mond untersuchen werden. Von daher wird es immer neue Daten geben in der internationalen Wissenschaftler- Gemeinde, die es dann auch gilt zu untersuchen und auszuwerten.
Vor allem so in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren.
Vor allem in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren. Und als Vergleichsobjekt zu anderen Körpern in unserem Sonnensystem oder auch generell zur Entstehung von Planeten, ist der Mond unverzichtbar. Da er uns als Einziger all diese Fülle an Informationen liefert und er der einzige Körper ist, von dem wir wirklich auch Proben am Boden haben und hoffentlich bald wieder welche bekommen.
Ja, Harald, dann sage ich vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zum Erdmond. Und auch vielen Dank hier wieder fürs Zuhören bei Raumzeit. Das war Ausgabe 39. Und wie schon angedeutet, wir stoßen hier bald noch etwas detaillierter in so ein System vor und nehmen uns auch noch andere Planeten vor. Aber bis dahin vergeht noch etwas Zeit. Ich wünsche euch noch viel Spaß. Bis bald.